[Music]
foreign
how does this work all right once the
dead man is revived we can ask him five
questions at which point he will die
again never to be re-revived I've had
questions I don't know that's just how
it works it seems arbitrary can we get
on with this place right yes
maybe I'm not saying it
I wasn't scared nearly startled
here we go
were you killed in the battle of the
Amber horse yes great I mean
not for you
sorry for your loss four more questions
right yes no no that wasn't for you did
that count as a question yes damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay yes
why did you say Okay at the end of that
I didn't
okay
fantastic where's the shovel
we're facing the greatest evil
the world is ever known
[Music]
foreign
Dungeons and Dragons
what a profound Joy it is to welcome you
the good people
for the resumption of the high Sun okay
not leave the arena until the close of
the games as there will be a wonderful
gift for each and every one of you
[Applause]
all right take me down this is absurdly
high it's not what we discussed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
so we just go through the maze I guess
till we reach the cage
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks
get out of the way
oh
another minute I would have lost my hand
y way to get onto the arena
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
dude
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
polo meets the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
she missed
no that's not good
I want you sick of failing we could die
there's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
this ends now
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
What creatures will you meet when you go
see the new movie Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves
oh that's not good
will there be an album
what is that again a mashup that somehow
carries all of the terror with none of
the cute from owls and bears
we're mimics monsters that compose as
anything
will there be a gelatinous cube that
disarms its victims how about a
displacer beast a predator with
tentacles and cloaking abilities and
well isn't that more than enough
oh an insulate Devourer a giant brain
that consumes other brains like some
kind of vocal brain cannibal the higher
the intelligence the prey the more
likely they are to strike
oh that's a little hurtful or even
member shot the red dragon who looks
like he ate all the other dragons as
appetizers
you'll just have to go see Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves to find out
the game started
Edgar is a Bard The Bard is sharp we
have a plan to have plan C fails
he's charming and bikeable
oh God I could kiss you try it
is a barbarian lives to fight foes and
everyone else luckily you can't make her
angry
because she's already angry
Simon is a sorcerer master of magic
[Music]
maybe I'm not saying it
is a druid change his shapes on the
outside
stays the same on the inside
is a paladin a warrior Associates and he
can afford to be polite
heals well good sir he's interesting
is a rogue trust him once shame on you
keep her safe you have my word trust him
twice
I don't see him die which is why I'm
Gonna Leave the Room then we have the
red wizard powerful and ruthless the
last face you want to see
and now you are ready to go out and see
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
you must have found a new Den did he eat
the last one
[Music]
oh I got a good feeling about this
dungeons of dragons is that classic
hero's journey we've got a ragtag group
of Misfits Where we have to fight
dragons and evil wizards in order to
save the world well how do we pull that
off uh figure it out over a drink
probably best
it's about finding your own hero within
and each character has their own version
of that Journey oh we got him now
exactly that you bring for this I'm a
planner I make plans I will not be
complicit in the illicitous booty can
someone else ride next to this guy I
think there's a wicked sense of humor
through this and that allows us to have
as much fun with this as we can he's
glad he's on our side the nuances that
each individual actor brings is what
makes this film so great
this I give you now trusting that you're
protected with your very life
I will
hold this
I'm part of the ruthless sand of Thieves
but he's not as evil as the red Wizard
never put your trust in a con man
The Dungeons and Dragons World has
amazing creatures in this one I think
they outdid themselves
these creatures are the same you really
can tell they put a lot into this what
is that again it's an hour back
[Music]
this is just big fun movie making
it's a great adventure for characters
that you're going to care about we want
to give them the movie that they've been
hoping for that's what I've been
sad
[Music]
thank you